Sacco you got it 13 was it 5s here we go
let's try e4 again here
b4 again
f6 f6 I'm gonna try it I'm gonna try
this I don't know if it's right but I'm
gonna go for it
I'm gonna go for it I won the last two
games with it I think they were faster
games or no no no no I played a bullet
game yeah I played a bullet game in a
five minute one I think I got both but
this is different
no this is different story isn't it it's
a different story
ah I'm not taking that paani what do I
have up my sleeve anything at all hmm
now what this is gonna be sneaky time
burner it's a time burner tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick okay I might
have to go burn time look for those time
burner moves oh oh
Knight takes Bonnie Queen h5e Oh what do
we got pileup
if I'm able to recapture on this square
with the piece then I have a clear three
pawns up oh it takes with tempo Knight
takes first none of the above
okay
hello pawn push threatening a fork
there's a couple takes I don't know if I
would have enough fuel to really disrupt
that King we're even on time ah did I
just take here and then try and get a
piece on this square I am a bit worried
about sax on h2 I got this might want to
do f4 f4 I might want to do that
Bishop b5 I'll probably take okay all
right I'm down two pawns but this rook
could turn into the big bad wolf rook up
and over doubled pawns liability or an
asset I'm on this guy twice there is
Bishop check but there is block and then
Queen takes pawn takes Bishop Queen
takes pawn so now what what's the story
you know the F pawn is coming after you
oh right here
there we go this has to be good look at
this it's a tsunami of pawns upon
tsunami a220 majority in the center
activity for the rook temple gainers
this is a temple gainer
there's no rush with that don't be silly
don't be silly you can get this move in
right now or later no rush no rush
calm down there calm down
d4 d5 these pieces are getting flushed
around two squares they're probably not
too happy with tsunami of pawns tsunami
of five pawns push
what's the rush what's the rush no rush
pine push next one two three four five
six seven they're probably gonna sack
back is it gonna be a sack back I got
this chase that night away chase it away
in fact I might want to do a bishop in
ooh f4 is a killer isn't it it's a
tsunami of pawns right here
I'm innocent anything tricks for or
checks that maybe I should have done
this before the King runs away to g8
yeah I should have done this move and I
should have considered it even before my
last will okay
a huge pond Senate huge pond center pond
push here pond push here night on f5
Queen on b3 bishop on g5 one day pond
push here here a lot of opportunities
that these Knights cannot rely upon is
square my opponent is up a knight but
where is its home right all right how
about my opponent is probably needing to
do give back something here so now Queen
check it seems brutal seems brutal let
me throw that in there
and then what that was stupid
Wow let me push this night around
actually there's that guy around Queen
takes pawn here bishop back here to
check I don't know if I'm worried about
that does the knight have to go home is
the knight too good for his home happy
gilmore happy gilmore there it is okay
that's a good spot to go forward with
giving the piece back I think very good
very very good very good very good so
now I shouldn't allowed that can I chase
that Queen away I don't I don't like
that she's so close really look up chase
the Queen back to one of these two
squares and then take the knight I have
this square covered there is a bishop
check I could run to the corner and my
back rank is still covered
ooh wait a second rook f3 there's 94 oh
okay
glad I saw that glad I saw it now I'm
going to do this bishop check King runs
to the corner and I just want to get
this move in next maybe I should have
done that earlier
okay Queen trade who has the safer King
do I really want to under the pawns no I
have to save for King and I don't want
to help out black by undoing their pawns
on push in fact let me do this I do not
like the thought of a knight coming to
g4 Bishop block Bishop counter block
let's just come here I'm not sure where
I want to go my bishop I have thoughts
of here still
although pawn push bishop check not too
concerned about that bishop check I
could just play there and now let's get
my knight here I'm on the bishop right
here Knight to g5 next okay let's take
this now Knight g5 my opponents in
trouble
this is hit twice defended zero I could
take it with check this is leading to
mate isn't it or something very close to
it
check
where is the that's me King had to go to
g8 oh but then I would have what I guess
I'd be able to flush my phone around no
matter what this was leading to mate
King g8 Queen h7 King f8 Queen h8 King
here Queen takes pawn Shack is also main
so it's mate no matter what I didn't see
that one though
good game let me see here let me see
backing up here I don't know if I should
have I think my opponent had an
opportunity to just go ahead and grab
that pawn I backed up I think he go
ahead with grabbing this and hold on
hang on tight hang on tight because I
think I'm able to still mess with black
if Knight takes I have been planning
Queen h5 pawn push is not good because
of Queen takes fork hitting Queen Knight
and King yeah king queen and night that
would be on e4 at that point if Queen
takes Bishop takes and then it's still
I'm on the king and night I get that
material back so if Knight takes Queen
h5 the King I believe has to go to mmm
well if it went to g8 that actually
leads to mate and if it plays its kind
of scary I guess maybe maybe taking here
isn't great because of Queen h5 I wonder
King e6 fried lever like King to e6
running towards the center I'm not sure
maybe here maybe here was another option
- no you can't take at that point not
sure
I'm not sure I don't know about pushing
the pun I wonder if supporting the pot
is good
something like c6 and then Knight to d7
and rook to e8 maybe that's better cuz I
think I'm I'm down still a point but
look at these beautiful pawns I think
this helps me out by the way the bish
inserting that bishop check I undone by
cons I still have you know this play
here and now I can start pushing forward
maybe I should have done that right away
in fact I think okay yeah I'm down
material but I won't be surprised if a
computer saying I'm better here just
because those pawns are very valuable
having two to zero in the center so
those are my quick suggestions I did
have to be cautious of the knight move
again at this point I was considering
rook f3 I think 94 is a strongly apply
avoid Queen exchange and then go after
that King that's why I've avoided the
Queen exchange I thought their King was
more vulnerable